I wish for eternal great poops they miss
what up fellow gangsters my name is
Pierre today it's my free day yesterday
was though so much fun
hi I got a time to reflect on the day it
was amazing
we're gonna go out today Marcy has a
plan for us and you brothers are coming
along it'll be fun you know it's a day
off when you're wearing shorts it's a
beautiful day all right so we're heading
to Little Tokyo never been a little
Tokyo before now we can be weebs
we're here so pretty
loser that is nice I want to wear that
I'll buy that when he opens oh my god
yes what even its oldest breakfast oh
they smell a really spicy night hmm
these are my favorite potato carrot and
broccoli you feel healthy even though
they're really bad for you miss it so
much this is like such a tiny piece of
it I notice I have battle wounds from
yesterday pretty hardcore time to update
my katana collection hope they sell
fedoras too
how nice very daring outfit that's
awesome
oh the masks I might buy the masks I
can't fit my face looks great I don't
know why I bought this but it's your
mask collection we all know yeah this is
awesome yes this is why I'm here
don't tell my Chan definitely building
this are you in heaven right now really
come everywhere
lunch time okay what do you got vanilla
why my tea take a bite
I destroyed this category and by
destroyed I mean I like half of it I'm
gonna eat machi Martin one shot but uh
you eat this
I don't understand watching Salman head
we're done here we're going to was a
call the Japanese garden I think I
recognized hey hey hi
so what Tommy what's so special by the
Japanese garden uh-huh amazing oh my God
look at this wow that's amazing so cool
it's like santorini hot I am sweating so
much it's like are we in LA or are we in
Japan I don't know
join it throw a coin I wish for eternal
great poops they miss what did I hit I
hit the rock today seriously okay I got
another chance
hired a blip oh yeah
what it's going on there someone should
do like a voiceover over this Oh little
bit a little bit that's yeah come here
I'm gonna take a pee so cute okay I
don't know what this is where we're
walking it Oh duck that's why you better
run [ __ ] I know what you're doing
where you going [ __ ] what so this is
how they process the water it's
amazingly to get all the water from
washing machine water and they process
it and that's what goes to the light
pretty damn elaborate what do you think
of the garden ready hey that's it yeah
it was amazing we're going back I'm
gonna take a nap for sure I'm so tired I
need a nap what West Nile virus yeah
we're gonna die I'm telling you now
wake up wake up but who
Macias been crazy are you know I'm about
to blow your mind with some food baby
okay yes oh god what a mess
what is this tortilla bread what the
[ __ ] Plan B pre-made salad I guess I
can't cook after all we didn't wait
would you like Italy to be different why
do they make it so [ __ ] hard can I do
it yeah special okay no good John oh my
god the croutons are soft that's strange
yeah it's not good but what are you
gonna do right says using a great tripod
over there professional youtubing right
now your shirt is Bill Murray from Life
Aquatic which is one of my favorite
movies Oh pom pom pom pom pom pom
there's one thing I really want to do
before and this vlog yeah oh another
great day today was my free day it's I'm
starting early tomorrow I am glad I got
to rest a bit I'm super stoked how well
these vlogs are doing I didn't expect it
at all it's so cool to see that you bros
really enjoy enjoy watching because i
really enjoy making these and i want to
make more so keep watching them alright
I'll see you both tomorrow as always
stay awesome
it's gonna be fine okay I trust you guys
I'll be oh god what the [ __ ] good good
good America can handle my [ __ ]